in this video i'm going to give you two
ways to identify how wealthy someone
else is going to be in the future and
how you can align yourself with those
individual character traits all right if
you don't know who i am my name is
austria moses i own acquisition.com it's
a portfolio of companies over 100
million a year and i have nothing to
sell you i make these videos because i
actually
enjoy doing it
all right so that being said this came
from a conversation that i was having
with a good friend of mine he exited his
company for just under half a billion
and we were just having like a
philosophical conversation around you
know what is it that makes people
successful and what are kind of the
things you can identify early or mindset
shifts in terms of perspective that
allow people to have an unfair advantage
and so if you followed any of my stuff i
talk a lot about time i talk a lot about
money and so it's unsurprising that the
two traits um have to do one with time
and the other with money and so one of
the things that's interesting about this
is the concept of measuring sticks a lot
of us have these base units that we
measure
things in and it's kind of like
shorthand that you use in your brain so
i'll give you a simple example so when i
was in high school i used to measure you
know how much money something was by the
amount of chipotle burritos i could buy
and because i used chipotle burritos
because it was an understandable like
quantity of value for me and so
everything was like how many chipotle
burritos is this and that was because
that was like the amount of money that i
was making and that was a material
amount of value for me at the time and
so one of obviously the measuring sticks
that people use is uh is is in money and
so the bigger the people that you hang
around with the bigger the unit of money
that they will measure things in in
terms of like base units and so for you
uh over time you want to increase what
that base unit looks like so you want to
start measuring things like how many 10k
units there are how many cars is this
how many houses is this how many
businesses is this right and even just
the amount of money itself how many 10ks
how many 100ks how many how many
millions there is and just as a as an
aside here in wall street in the hedge
fund world they have a term that i
learned probably a couple years ago
which is a stick right and a stick is
their measuring unit which is a million
dollars so they're like yeah give them a
stick or put two sticks in and they say
that because they have these measuring
units that are significantly bigger than
most people can fathom or imagine but
because our brains think in units and so
if you can hang around people whose base
unit of measurement around money is far
greater than yours then you will start
chunking up and thinking about money in
those greater terms and all of a sudden
for example let's say your base unit of
money is a hundred thousand dollars or
ten thousand dollars even then it makes
it much less likely for you to go
participate in an activity right that's
going to generate you a hundred dollars
or a thousand dollars because it's not
even a full unit of measurement so it's
like almost why bother and what happens
and the difference between rich dads and
poor dads and what they teach their kids
is that rich dads in general will teach
their kids to go after higher leverage
opportunities they'll go after
opportunities that have bigger base
units of measurement bigger base units
of money that they can compile together
right and so the first thing you can do
in terms of identifying in other people
and then also within yourself is what
unit of measurement did they use are
they using chipotle burritos right are
they using thousand dollar units are
they using ten thousand dollar units are
they using million dollar units right so
the bigger the unit of measurement
they're using for money likely the
wealthier they are and the wealthier
they become because they only will
participate in activities that can be
measured in those units so that's number
one number two is measurements around
time and so this is uh and this is has
an interesting kind of like part a and
part b to it so part a
is that they uh on a micro scale within
like day to day they're going to act
faster they're going to
be better utilizers of their time in
general and on the micro side it's just
about speed it's about execution speed
if you start interacting with somebody
and their speed of communication is
rapid in terms of their turnaround time
in terms of when they communicate with
you in terms of how they respond to
things you can be sure that that person
is far more active and i'll give you a
reason for why people move forward so
much faster in life when they have that
you're trying to get something done
right and let's say that you you message
someone and then you know they wait a
day and they message you back and then
you wait a day and you message them back
and then let's say it takes five
interactions like this to to get this
project done so that would be ten days
like you one day then one day five times
right and so that would be 10 days now
imagine a different scenario where you
have two people who are wealthier in
terms of how they manage their time
right how they leverage their time and
they're able to have that entire
exchange within a matter of 30 minutes
right and now if you look at the
difference between a 30 minutes and 10
days it dramatically compresses the time
to achieve the result and then this is
where it gets interesting now after that
30 minutes let's say they do that again
and again and again and again in a very
real way they will have accomplished
more literally in a day than other
people will try and accomplish in a
month or more right and this is how you
compress time and you can drag your
future into the present by increasing
the speed with which you take action and
you communicate with other people all
right so that is the part a micro uh for
time now part b of time is macro and so
this is an important one when it comes
to measuring sticks and also again with
the measuring sticks on the first one
because i really just want to drive this
point home i made a video about this but
it's it's the idea of switching from end
of week being your default to switching
to end of day or right now being your
default so how can i just make the
default in my company end of day like if
no one says anything it has to be done
by end of day right or how can i say
that my new default is by four hours
from now right and so that becomes your
new micro measuring step in terms of how
quickly you can get things done and
reply and move things forward et cetera
so you want to deal with people who have
very condensed micro push things forward
in terms of their activities and how
they see things getting done on the
macros perspective it's when people are
talking about decades and not days right
and so you can tell how wealthy someone
is by their perspective on time in terms
of how long they are willing to wait to
see something through and so this is
kind of like a very extrapolated version
of the marshmallow test if you've never
heard of that it's pretty famous test
where they have two kids and they they
said hey you can have a marshmallow now
or i can give you two marshmallows in a
few minutes and the kids who said i want
the marshmallow now and couldn't use the
self-restrainer self-control were
significantly less wealthy less
successful later in their lives compared
to the kids who
could wait for the second marshmallow
and if you wanted to add an interesting
wrinkle to this you could make the
marshmallow even further out what about
if the marshmallow was in five hours
what if the marshmallow was the two
marshmallows for tomorrow what if the
two marshmallows were a week from now
what if the two marshmallows were a year
from now right and i can guarantee that
the person who had the furthest out date
of when they were willing to restrain
themselves would be significantly more
successful and that is because impulse
control or self-restraint is one of the
key drivers of success because you can
see where you're trying to go and it
takes from a macro perspective a long
time to build amazing things right rome
wasn't built in the day which is a quote
that is said all the time but people
don't actually live by it and so if you
surround yourself with people who use
measuring sticks of money that are
significantly larger than yours they
have micro units of time that are
significantly shorter than yours they
get things done faster they communicate
faster they move things forward faster
right and then in terms of how they
measure the goals that they want to
achieve in their life they measure in
decades instead of days or weeks or
months if you surround yourself and you
give yourself those three which is two
with you know two with two micros uh
the lens is through rich to see other
people and then also to judge yourself
you will be significantly better off and
you will move far more rapidly towards
the goals that you want to achieve and
so anyways this was a this was a
paraphrasing conversation i had with a
good friend of mine um i thought i would
share it with you guys because you guys
are awesome and i'm just so grateful
that you guys enjoy this stuff uh please
you know let me know in the comments if
there's other things you'd like me to
kind of outline again nothing to sell
you and if you uh do like this stuff
like subscribe share um it uh it helps
the youtube gods uh share it to more
people so anyways keep being awesome as
a nation love you and i'll see you guys
next video bye